no so they're still saying what is the
deal with you and Ethan being serious
for a minute this is amazing says red
delicious thank you red I heard from
Mason that they were mad at me uhuh I
don't actually know
why didn't you say why when I I dm'd
Ethan did he answer it may have been
over how we a fan maybe who had stopped
to visit I it possibly may be that I
don't know the whole thing but I dm'
Ethan because I love Ethan and you know
I love Ethan too I love you and I I come
out here All for Love I don't come out
here for money I just you know want to
get famous and be loved by everybody and
uh I don't want anybody mad so it may
have been over a fan and it may have
been what does that fan um there is a
fan who came up to see us on the weekend
who I don't think they like and oh
what's that and uh oh we have uh I
thought maybe somebody had Mexican food
for a minute but anyway no we have the
oran guys here now it may have been over
that and then I think they're they don't
like the fan and I think they got maybe
mad at me but I I didn't know all that I
think it was an accidental thing and I
think that that possibly may be it
that's what I'm thinking but nothing was
done in any like malicious way Howie it
was just you know
um a fan a girl that wanted to come up
and and and hang out so I think maybe
that's it all right well you didn't
bring a girl with you today did you no I
have my social media people I have uh
Dan and I have Mitch but Harry I do want
to say something important are you using
a filter what do you mean when you're on
camera are you using a filter it looks
like you're using a filter I don't know
what you mean like a filter like on the
on the lens to make you look uh like sof
use a filter on our podcast I'm just
looking in the camera right now it looks
like he's using a filter that's all I'm
saying oh so I have some big news Howie
hang on big news is coming every big
news is coming Jesus you don't think it
looks like a filter it does it does are
you using a filter on this uh broadcast
oh here this is a call coming in right
now hello you're live on Howe Mandel
does
stuff yeah I know I've been I've been
watching you guys live
Ethan hello Jimmy can you hear me hey
yeah yeah we're actually just talking
about
you I know I was listening I appreciate
the kind things that you guys
said well can I say something
eth you said something nice I said Thank
I would never in a zillion years for all
the love I got from you and I think what
happened with the girl was she was a fan
and wanted to come hang and I didn't
know you guys how your feelings were to
you told me and I'm sorry I took the
post down and I would never ever ever do
anything to ever do anything wrong with
you and and I told Zach that it just
love me even if you don't have me come
on it's fine but I just don't want you
to be mad at me because I would never do
nothing bad well I'm not mad you're just
on Ice that happens occasionally you
know what I mean like everybody we we we
do polls occasionally and we did do one
and the audience they're almost there
Jimmy they're at about 40% say yes okay
we could just get that 50 we just get
that extra
11% I'm here tomorrow I'm not going home
till Saturday I'm around I'd love to
come over and see you okay so if you
have a message to our fans uh influence
them back on the show what would you say
look the camera I would say that that's
your camera right there I would say that
I got DM by a girl who wanted to come
hang out with me I'm all about having
Entourage around me you know that's just
how I feel I like having a group of
people and she came up and there were a
couple friends that came with her and we
hung out a little bit Saturday and a
little bit on Sunday and that was
totally it and you sound like James
Charles sounds very similar to James
Charles no I'm I'm a fun guy that likes
to hang out with a lot of people and
have fun aren't you a married guy aren't
you married hold on I'm married but howy
all the girl hold on Jimmy hold on yeah
how old is this girl she's in her 20
she's my son's age she's like 21 or5 or
23 but here's the point nothing happen
oneone dinner with her Jimmy I can't
hear you did you have a one-on-one
dinner with her I had dinner with her
and my my well put on your headset
social media people put on your headset
he doesn't want to mess up his hair yeah
oh I had dinner with Danny Mitch and me
and her on Sunday night I see how it
makes it looks bad and it's putting H3
and Ethan in a predicament because it's
one of their fans and then you take them
out yeah but then hold on jacine then I
find out for that's just one part of it
wait minute then I find out from Ethan
that they they don't like her and they
make her feel uncomfortable and then I
said well if I'm sorry even met her and
I apologize and I wish I never met her
and they were all mad at me when
honestly nothing was done hold on Jimmy
you're not being totally forthcoming
because so this this girl I don't know
her none of us know her we just know her
because she somehow always gravitates to
people that are close to us
the show people that we about first it
was um Gabe and this poor you know she
was
really Gabe was interested in her and he
talked about her all the time and she
was just like
constantly I don't know toying with him
leaving him on or something and but then
always showing up to trying to show up
to our events and stuff and she's in all
of our DMS and she's reaching out to
everybody trying to get close to us
so it's uncomfortable behavior and we
told you that Jimmy we told you that
before this new round photos We Told You
So Zach mentioned to me last time I was
in that she's a Cloudchaser he told me
that absolutely you're
right what did he tell you Jimmy told me
last time I was in town was when was I
here last what is this what did he he
said she was a cloud chaser and came to
his
show and she don't bother with her he
did tell me that
I think he probably said more than that
well he did tell me I'm not going to
deny
it and did you tell him last time that
you weren't gonna you were gonna no she
found out I was coming and she was dming
me and I said if you want to come hang
out come hang out I said find a place to
stay you're not staying at my place and
she found some friends to stay with and
she hung out with us a little on the
weekend and with my whole group of
people it was all of us it was a whole
group of
people Jimmy posted a ton of photos of
them together on Instagram just the two
of them I was tagging her and stuff I've
never talked about this girl I don't
know her I taged some pictures we it
sounds pretty sketchy like for your wife
honestly I mean I don't think jacine the
last thing on my mind at my age with the
wife I have and my business career I
like fans and fomo and fun that isn't me
at all never has been fomo can you know
what Jimmy fomo can also mean well I'm
learning the hard way out on intimate
connections I'm learning the hard way in
fact you can bring Dan in right now and
ask Dan because he'll tell you the truth
you want to bring Dan in Dan was with me
all weekend he'll tell you Dan's trying
not to uh be part of it tell tell him
the truth he doesn't he doesn't want to
tell him the truth who's Dan Dan with me
the en TR I've been with Jimmy Dan's the
guy I brought down when I was on your
show nothing sketch's gone on he just
loves his fans he saw as a but I want
Dan to tell you the truth because the
furthest thing Ethan H as a person is
this guy with you now yeah Dan Dan come
here I I think I okay D he can't he
can't he'll he'll hear he'll sit there
sit there and put on the headset so you
can hear better no but Ethan can't hear
Dan unless he Dan you were sit there let
him sit here I feel awful Ethan that's
that's what you think that was it was
just a talk into the mic and put on the
headset I don't think it doesn't sound
like the end of the road for you guys
though it doesn't sound like you're
banished I would never do that to a girl
there're just fans that want to v no I'm
not the girl I mean from Ethan I from
Ethan you thought you were
I don't even want to have anything to
do Dan tell a hoe and Ethan the truth
hey what's up Ethan yeah I've been with
Jimmy 247 from he's since he's been up
to bed um every time he was with her I
was around it was a group nothing
sketchy went on he just saw her as a fan
you know how he is with his fans he
loves his fans so um yeah you don't got
to worry bro it's nothing's catch never
was like that never would be like that
by the way let me say this I trust Jimmy
I don't think he did anything un It's
just sometimes the the audience and fans
could make it seem worse than the
situation is depending on how had a
conversation about this before and then
he just you know in one ER and out the
other but Ethan I'm all about fomo and
fans I'm not about young girls and
hanging out like that I'm married and I
don't care about that that's not me it
doesn't it was more just like the
stalkerish Behavior it wasn't about the
young girl well we we did find out how
she is once you dm' me and I said to you
I took that one image down and I said
I'm not even going to have nothing to do
with the girl you guys got so upset at
me up with her Jimmy you took one image
down I did not ask you to do that for
the no I did it out of I did it out of
respect for you you didn't ask me I did
it I know I know let me go to your
Instagram because there's he let's see
here there may be one up with I have
Demi levado in one and I have one with
katop but the one that so you have two
photos of her from this weekend still
right because one's with katop and one's
with Demi levada but put it up here so
we can see what other ones I took down I
kept the other ones up had celebrities
in what do you guys make of that wait
wait wait I'm gonna they haven't we
don't have it up yet we're going to I
understand his point if it's with other
celebrities Hees the only reason I kept
them up because celebrities but you can
also take it down and edit her out and
repost with the other celebrities or put
something over her face so it's very
apparent that you don't want of you with
her Jimmy if you run into a celebrity
and you want to take a photo just take
it the two of you why what do you think
happened what you Ethan what do you
think happened she ran into the picture
ask she ran into the picture tell him
hold hold on Dan tell them what happened
when we took the picture listen Ethan
you jumped in pictures Jimmy's not over
there reaching out saying hey come take
a picture of I don't see the pictur you
see pict L obviously you scroll down
Jimmy there's one they're in there but
the girl R into pictures Ethan we're not
LED in instagam so we not go go down
further no it's okay I'm going to find
it on my end and send it to you no if
you keep going you'll find them they
they can't right now no because we're
going so let me ask Daniel Daniel you're
saying that she jumped into the photo
she R yeah he's not over there telling
he's not over there telling hey you or
you come take a picture of me especially
when he's with a celebrity obviously
he's thinking about celebrity and then
she just pops in she ran into and then
at Sunday we realized we were in trouble
right towards the end of the
day what what what made you realize you
were in trouble well she's uh uh you're
taking me for dinner I came all the way
up to see you and I'm like uh no and
then uh after seven times uh I gu take
you for dinner so it was all of us it
was all of us for dinner so we went to
are you saying she was coming on to you
Mitch and her for dinner did what did
you say she was coming on to you Jimmy I
don't think she was coming on to me I
think she's a CL oh by the way Howe
don't show the photo of her on second
thought obviously just CL oh too late I
see it no it's not too late I see it's
too late it's up there because it's up
there no it's not it's okay so we won't
show it we're not showing it but I have
it and you can block off her face I
don't know whatever you guys want I
don't want no I don't want anyone to
okay but I do see it I don't want people
to know who she is I don't want to cause
any trouble for
her is this Carrot Top picture when he
got Carrot Top for you on your for your
podcast no that Carrot Top Sunday was
there Sunday in uh in my hotel how when
I came back from dinner see katop came
back to his hotel with him katop came
back to his you're a married guy carot
toop was at the hotel the boor when we
came back from dinner oh but this is
very easy Jimmy if you wanted to take
these down edit it and like put them
back up yeah and I'm very how good am I
with social with doing that Dan awful oh
stop it Jimmy you you're surrounded by a
full team of social media Wizards we'll
take care of it e don't worry about it
it'll be done by the time so you were
saying Ethan that if he makes a plea to
the to your audience to see if you can
get the are you taking some sort of poll
to see how many people get back on I
want to be on but they the other day but
they said yeah we do po we do live polls
dur talk to his audience on that camera
and tell them what you'll do before
before that if you don't mind jimy I
want to compel some more information
from Daniel before we before we take a
vote
Dan sitting right
here
goe go ahead um so Daniel did this do
this ever make you uncomfortable at any
situation this is you thought this isn't
appropriate Jimmy I wish you didn't what
do you meite her I wish you didn't talk
to her I wish you didn't do this like
did you ever have any thoughts like that
with I mean with her honestly I didn't
know too much about the lore of that so
I kind of just noticed her as a fan she
I saw her as a person I didn't know like
the internet or you know what the fans
were saying on the internet before that
so I just got to know her as a person
she didn't she didn't do any SK anything
sketchy to me she didn't she was just a
normal kid she didn't do anything weird
with me so personally as just a person
to person she seemed fine to me but um
now that you're revealing all this
information it is kind of kind of
sketchy I I would
agree
okay okay Jimmy so thank you Daniel
thank you we appreciate your your
honesty
is Jimmy paying you yet Daniel oh he's
yeah he's tossing me a few bucks now a
little bit I am now yes he's helping me
out especially now that coming well he
came from Texas he moved so I am helping
him out yeah he's helping me
out y he's helping you out okay I have
to because he doesn't live here anymore
oh he's helping me out with money yes
like he's help how much money did he
give you I'm giving it to him at the end
he's gonna be it's G to be a he's
helping me reimburse for like the I'm
reimbursing for things it's honestly
this this trip for me this year is kind
of like a vacation cuz I just moved back
to Texas so um yeah so but then but so
you're justifying that you paid for it
what was that what you say so you but it
sounds like you're paying for everything
not everything no no he's toting me a
few bucks but but yeah I am paying for
for he paid and I'm reimbursing him
that's what we're
doing okay you're doing a full
reimbursement
Jimmy I am figuring out the end of the
trip what I have to pay him and I'm
paying him
all right yes I want I want you to
reimburse him for everything Jimmy okay
and I want you to also add $500 for him
for time for stomach lining and heart
muscle so if he reimburses him is Jimmy
allowed back on the podcast well that's
up to the people no I'm gonna reimburse
him anyway whether I go back on the
podcast or not
audience doesn't have a great track
record with this stuff because he lots
of our fans who just want to be
be part of the show or be part of Jimmy
because he's such a legendary character
um he he just he'll exploit them for for
free labor frankly and um I I you know I
think Jimmy you and Jimmy's a rich guy
you guys know that the man he's he's a
he's a dentist extraordinaire the man
was driving a Rolls-Royce for pizza's
sake you know
um so they do can afford it yeah but so
so but here the point is that I think
that these things that are bothering you
Ethan are things that he isn't doing
maliciously as much as I'm not that type
of person no I know I know I looked at
this girl as a fan she
DM Ethan all right
just say something tell Ethan yeah Ethan
I I feel like I feel like sometimes I'm
I'm a big HD fan I've been a fan for a
long time dude but I feel like sometimes
the fans could be a little sensitive and
sometimes they can make big situations
out of small situations when I'm out
with Jimmy it's not like I'm doing
manual labor Ean I'm snapping a few
photos at dinner he's paying my dinner
we're hanging out at the hotel you know
we're just chatting up meeting cool
people meeting older people making
connections I got to meet how I got to
meet carrot I got to meet a bunch of
celebrities met trying to getv person so
for me it's worth it I don't feel like
I'm being exploited I feel like we're
we're doing a fair exchange here and you
know he's tossing me some money as well
so I feel like some of the fans might
see it as super expl like I'm being like
I don't know used or something but I
don't want you guys to like make it seem
like Jimmy's this type of evil guy
that's taking ad advantage of your fans
or anything like that because that's not
the case at all just want to make that
clear you got you got a great guy over
there with youim got a very loyal guy he
came from another state for me and he
moved and I got him and I got peebler I
got a few really just like you have you
know rich and and Ethan has his crew and
I think a lot of times the H3 fans
misunderstand me and I don't mean my
comedy because me as a person and you
and my wife will say this Jim is a lot
of things but he'll give you the shirt
off his back and he'll do anything for
you we never hurt anybody and then when
we first met I I I saw that in you and
that's why I'd like you some I said
thank you you are a really nice person
thank you well you the reason you're
here is Ethan you know Ethan called me I
know Ethan called me so I'm just saying
you know he is a supporter of people I
have to say though Ethan the people in
I know and I love
Ethan I'm his number one supporter I'm
his I'm his biggest advocate in the
world I know and I love you Ethan we
have people in our chat in our Super
Chat that's saying Ethan please have him
back
raxon okay well it's not up to me listen
our podcast is and will always be a
democracy for the People by the people
right unless I disagree with
anything that's funny that's funny so
but anyway Daniel you're a good man
appreciate it thank you that was nice
Ethan you called because I after we DM
the other day I surmised that's what it
was that girl I'm running out of time
Jimmy so so we have a show we're doing
our Friday show tomorrow Jimmy yeah so
if you want to make a plea to the people
and then I'll show it to the people and
afterwards we'll take another vote so
look in that camera right there so I
make a ple T Street people we do have to
hurry up though because to uh come back
on your podcast but here's the one thing
say I leave Saturday so do I come
tomorrow or I don't come I only have one
more no this is this is to just to have
you back at any time so just make a plea
into that camera why you should be back
on HD well number one I think I get
misunderstood that thing that happened
with the girl which because she was a
fan and wanted to hang out and that's
all it was and I don't have a mean bone
in my body I'm not going to do anything
to harm people and I love you guys you
support me you help me I would love to
come back but it's up to you guys not me
but I'm here tomorrow but I leave
Saturday there's your plea Ethan you got
it and Ethan I do love you and it was
nice you called Ethan he hung up he hung
up okay he hung up well I'll say again
he was nice you called okay it was so
well thank you Jimmy Lee thank you have
a nice day while you're here how can I
just plug something yeah and then I'll
go there's a fan fair tomorrow down at
Pink's Hot Dogs if anybody wants to come
down about 1:00 there's going to be a
braid of people radio people tomorrow uh
so if anybody's wants to come down it's
a like it's for like about an hour and a
half
tomorrow at an hour and a half tomorrow
at pink Frid Friday at pink hot dogs
tomorrow 1 they might get a dinner out
of it right we love to have our fans
well they get get dinner out of it I'm
trying to talk to R uh Rich Pink's uh
social media person like the first so
many people get a jersey Outlaw hot dog
free I'm working on that right now with
so that's you don't know uh I didn't get
an answer back yet we should contact
Raina and see if she'll go there any um
at Pink's Hot Dogs with all your fans
yeah it doesn't matter anyway go go to P
I can't because I'm I'm working I'm my
way to Vegas I'm playing Vegas this
Saturday with preacher Lawson Westgate
Casino I saw I'll be there Saturday
night so come see me Saturday night well
I always appreciate uh how you're that
you love me and you have me on I really
love you and I love your daughter you I
mean that thank Youk you for coming
we're thanks buddy we're going to bring
some animals in now right is that what
we're doing now so we
have's calling back hang
on hi Ethan you're on Jam still there
yeah yeah just okay I just wanted Jimmy
to know I did not hang up the call that
dropped oh okay and I was I was watching
you did The Plea thank you and then
we'll we'll take it from here okay thank
you dear good luck buddy thank you thank
you dear H all right thank you honey
love you honey thank you love bug love
you love bug bye stay healthy
[Music]
buddy
I